EXPERIENCED A WIN, THEY BEATAT
BOB: PASS
SHORTSIDE IS GAUDREAU.
THAT'S COVERED UP BY SWAYMAN.THS
CREATES THE BASE FOR THE SHOT.
BERGERON ENDS UP HAVING AN OPEN
SHOT.
LOOSE IN THE BLUE PAINT.
NG OPPORTUNITY.
KICKS AWAY GAUDREAU'S SHOT.
A ONE-TIME LEFT WITH THE
FOUR-ON-THREE.AY GOAL OF THE
SEASON. FROMAVE TO KNOW
THAT KAPRIZOV IS ON THAT A ROCKM
MAY GET A DEFLECTION ON IT IN
FRONT RIGHT THERE.
HARD TO TLE PICK IT MAKES HIS
LIFE DIFFICULT.
LEAGUE GOAL TO STRETCH THE WILD
LEAD TO 3-1! MADE
SEVERAL GOOD PLAYS ON THE POWER
PLAY.
HE'S LOOKED COMFORTABLE.
THE
HAD HIS POCKET PICKED.
ZOOM
SAVED.
THE REBOUND.
SCUFFED ON
THEY'RE WITHIN ONE.
HIS BACKHAND.
LOOK AT THAT GAPING NET.
NOT
ZUCCARELLO HAS IT.
WRWR JEREMY SWAYMAN.
YOU CUT THE DEFICIT TO ONE.
THE PRESSURE HERE BY HARTMAN. OE
WEAKSIDE THAT WAS PUT ONL BE STN
BOSTON.
AND YOU WONDER HOW IT'S STRAIGHO
THE FOREHAND OF HEARTMAN.
AND SWAYMAN WAS ABLE TO COVER IT
UP WITH
HARTMAN
A VERY BRIEF BOSTON POWER PLAY.
GRZELCYK PUTS IT INTO THE BLUE
AND
BUT TO GET TO THAT INSIDE, I
THINK THE HELP BY ZUCCARELEL ISS
EMPTY!
THE QUICK SHOT
MARCHAND HAS IT.
EIGHT SECONDS TO GO.
WRISTER IN TRAFFIC.
BY CAB THENN
-- KAHKONEN.
HE'S ABLE TO HOLD
AND DOES.
MARCHAND.EPARE FOR